when beyonce says can you pay my bills
can you pay my telephone bills we used
that to explain beyonce wouldn't need
anyone to pay her bills if she would
just save for an emergency fund of three
to six months of her expenses beyonce
could pay for her own bills and kids are
getting it
goal setter is a savings financial
education and investment platform
founded by tanya van court created for
the entire family goal setter aims to
teach kids an adult's financial literacy
through memes quizzes and incentives
tanya decided to found the company after
her daughter asked for a bike and enough
money to open an investment account for
her 9th birthday
tanya attributes her daughter's
impressive financial literacy to her own
focus on the subject after she lost
hundreds of thousands of dollars in the
dot-com bubble
my million dollars in stock and stock
options suddenly plummeted to about
twenty thousand dollars in a single day
and i realized at that moment that it
was really stupid that i had not
diversified the money
and so i thought well i can't turn back
the hands of time but i can make sure
this never happens to my kids the work
that goal setter is doing is so
important because
america has never taught us about how to
be
savers or investors
america has only taught how to be
consumers
and america has taught so many of us how
to be consumers because
that whole contingent of consumerism
fuels the wealth in america there are
many teen debit card companies that will
gladly put a debit card into your team's
hand and let them have easy access to
their own cash and your cash we're not
that our debit card comes with a rule
called learn before you burn so your
teen's debit card will automatically
freeze on sunday morning if they haven't
taken their financial literacy quiz for
the week yet we believe that there is no
reason we should be putting the
responsibility of spending into kids
hands without giving them the knowledge
of saving and investing to
before goal setter tanya ran digital
strategy at nick jr noggin and discovery
there she learned how to create engaging
content for kids she also oversaw the
rollout of digital textbooks for
children at discovery giving her
first-hand experience with how children
learn
the amazing thing about being at
nickelodeon and discovery education was
i had the opportunity to see firsthand
how when you bring entertainment and
media and pair that with education it
truly has the opportunity to change kids
lives so we have completely transformed
how we address and how we bring
financial education to kids and to
adults in a way that they have never
experienced in america before
we use memes and gifs from popular
culture from in instagram influencers
from recording artists in order to
explain key financial concepts tanya has
been open about her difficulties around
fundraising she even notoriously turned
down mr wonderful on shark tank when the
deal didn't meet her terms
but in january of 2021 goal setter
closed a 3.9 million dollar seed round
that included billionaire robert f smith
and nba stars kevin durant and chris
paul
in december 2021 they closed a 15
million dollar series a that included
nba star carmelo anthony and actor
anthony anderson
so the second question i had to ask
myself was do you really believe that
you're asking people for a favor when
you're asking them to invest in you do
you believe that you're giving them an
opportunity
and in my heart of hearts i believed
that i was giving them an opportunity an
opportunity to be a part of an
extraordinary company with an
extraordinary future that absolutely has
the potential to be the next unicorn but
i had to convey that
so that when i'm pitching to people i am
expressing and explaining this
opportunity as just that an opportunity
and not a charity case
and once i came to grips with that i was
in a much better position to have a
conversation about why investing in goal
setter was not just good for goal setter
but it was really good for the people
who we were asking to invest
and tonya is taking full advantage of
this opportunity in october in
conjunction with robert f smith
goalsetter launched the one stock one
future initiative to help one million
black and latino kids become
shareholders in public stock
goal setter also rolled out a business
to business platform where companies and
financial institutions can give goal
setters offerings to their employees or
customers so far golcera has partnered
with companies like fiserv twitter and
hp among others
we're in a crisis in america we can't
live in one america where we are relying
upon each other if we are not willing to
share the future of america with
everyone who is a part of this economy
and so the work that we're doing is the
work that should have always been done
in america a work that prepares every
american to understand financial
wellness to understand how to build
wealth and to be prepared to be a part
of the economic fabric in this country
that lets them be an owner and an
investor and not just a consumer